- [Voiceover] The only
common oxide of zinc
has a formula ZnO, zinc and
then you have your oxygen.
Write the electron
configuration for a zinc atom
in the ground state.
So there's a couple of
ways that you could do this
for the electron configuration.
Let's first identify zinc on
our periodic table of elements,
and this is the actual one
that they will give you
when you take the AP test.
And so we have zinc right over here,
zinc right over there,
and there's a couple
of ways you could do it.
The simplest way is starting with the
noble gas that is before zinc,
so that would be argon right over here.
You could say it's going to have the same
electron configuration as argon, argon.
Let me...
So you're gonna have argon
but then you're going to go
and you're gonna add the four,
you're gonna add electrons
to the 4s subshell.
So you'll go 4s1, 4s2.
So argon and then you have 4s2,
and then you go and--
it's an oversimplification
what I'm about to say,
but when you're figuring
out electron configurations,
it's helpful to think of
well, after you figure out
fill in the s subshell,
then you go and backfill
the 3d subshell.
So 3d1, 3d2, 3d3, 3d4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So 4s2 3d10.
And there's two exceptions
in this fourth row here.
You have the exceptions
of chromium and copper
that don't exactly fill just like that.
You can look those up on your own,
but that right over here is
the electron configuration
for a zinc atom in the ground state.
Now another way you could write this
is actually writing out
the electron configuration
for argon and then writing 4s2 3d10,
and we'll just for the
sake of it, let's do that.
So you fill up your 1s2.
So we go 1s2,
and then we're in the second row,
so you're gonna have 2s2 and then 2
one, two, three, four, five, six, 2p6.
2s2 2p6.
So let me write that down.
And then you're going
to go to the third row,
so you're gonna have--
and if this looks
completely foreign to you,
I encourage you to watch
the Khan Academy videos
on electron configuration.
And then you're gonna have 3s2 3p6.
You're gonna fill those
two subshells next.
3s2 3p6, and then what
we've just described
is essentially the electron
configuration of argon,
and so then you get to 4s2 and 3d10.
4s2 and 3d10.
So either of those would do,
and then the second part.
From which sublevel are electrons
removed when a zinc atom
in the ground state is oxidized?
And this is what's interesting
about d block elements,
and that's why I said
it's a little more nuanced
than saying you're kind of
constructing this electron
by electron and you fill these in,
the 4s2 and then you
go and backfill the 3d
because it actually
turns out when you have
a neutral zinc atom, the
highest energy electrons,
the ones that are the most
likely to be pulled away
from the zinc atom are
not the d electrons.
It's actually going to
be the 4s2 electrons.
So from which sublevel
are electrons removed?
Well, the most likely to
be removed not the first to
is going to be the 4s electrons.
So the 4s sublevel.
And once again, I encourage
you to kinda read more
about that if you're
curious about why that is.
You can kind of imagine in your head.
Even when you look at energy levels,
the 3d sublevel and 4s are
very, very, very close,
but it does turn out that most of the time
what's going to react are the ones
that are furthest out, the 4s1.
So you could argue that
those are at the highest
energy level, and so when you oxidize,
you start pulling electrons off of zinc,
you can pull off the 4s.
You're more likely to
pull off the 4s electrons
or you're going to pull
off the 4s electrons.